you mentioned
hyenas is your favorite animal i forgot
to ask you
what the hell were you thinking why is
hyena is your favorite animal
yeah it's um it's a fascinating animal
and
let's look at the whole animal kingdom
like why is that where do you put
so you like dogs love my favorite your
favorite is dogs
but they're kind of outside the animal
kingdom because you're thinking about
wolves
so the animal kingdom is in nature dogs
escaped nature they kind of did yeah
together with humans like in a
collaborative way
exactly so within nature within the
animal kingdom
what who's uh why not lions that's their
brains are predictable
lions are just you know they're regal
and kind of boring it's like the hot
chick it's like we get it
you were born the best yeah you know i
like a scrappy
by any means necessary intelligent and
cunning
uh but aren't they dishonest yeah and
that's why i like them
yes they're dishonest they employ
chicanery
they uh they're and that's just a sign
of how intelligent they are and how
self-reliant they
are and how brutal they are um they're
brutally honest
in how much they lie yeah you know
because it's just
they're trying to get the job done yeah
you know lions are just like
they're they're too gifted everyone
hates the [ __ ]
you know if i went to school with you
i'd be like of course lex knows the
[ __ ] answer
lex was born smarter than me yeah you
know and you'd probably hate me
because i was the kid always seeking
attention and making people
it's like that's not interesting the guy
that claws his way to the top and those
are hyenas
they're also fascinating just by uh
merely who they are i mean they're not
related to any other animal they're
more closely related to cats than they
are dogs even though they look
still yeah they're but they're very like
very tangentially related even to cats
so they're their own kind of thing which
is kind of mysterious i don't think they
fully figured out
and uh they this pseudo penis thing is
the is the i mean
it is they explain the pseudo penis yeah
so the
it's a matriarchal society by the way so
that's unique in and of itself that this
we're talking about an apex predator
that is uh matriarchal much like uh you
know the praying mantis it's very rare
though
and they are [ __ ] brutal and vicious
and the women are bigger
and they let their cubs fight a lot of
fracture side and they do that because
they're like hey
you're weaker they let your brother kill
you and uh the women have penises
the women have pseudo-penises that they
give birth out of and the birth is
violent
but they they roll around with just huge
pieces their glue guns are just [ __ ]
swinging
you know and the women are just run the
show and
uh it's just cool that they have these
pseudo penises
uh it's almost romantic the way you eat
this they have the strongest bite force
they they pulverize bone like when they
eat an animal the animal's gone
there's no bones they eat everything
they can pulverize
their bite is so powerful they pulverize
bone and eat it
so if they consume an animal it the
animal was there and then the animal's
gone there's no
nothing for the vultures there to uh to
to grab
yeah i'm gonna have to revisit the
hyenas because my experience with the
genius was
from uh first of all history hanging as
your show
has rebranded them for me but the lion
king
which is a a cartoon i guess
that i get emotional that every time i
have a i hope
i probably have father issues everyone
every guy probably just
you just have feelings you're a good guy
i mean everyone has that yeah yeah
that one gets everybody i don't know i
get i get every father-son
movie like blow with johnny depp uh and
uh ray liotta damn that's a good movie
and whenever there's like um like the
disappointment in the father that his
son has become like
this incredibly successful drug lord
that then ends up with nothing
in in in prison uh just the sadness of
them communicating through letters man
it gets me every time
but yeah but you know uh they're the
hyenas are not presented that well in
that um
no they're usually portrayed as like uh
it's really
sad that they're portrayed that way
lions like lions aren't dicks
lions are dicks they the the the the
alpha lions will kill the cubs of
another rival they do all types of dick
[ __ ]
yeah and um yeah it's uh the hyenas are
more interesting like they'll just roll
in like a hyena will like
like you said the lie you know because
when you watch the serengeti
you know animals will hang out with each
other they're like by water
so one hyena will just kind of roll in
and pretend like it's not hungry
and then bang they'll use any
means necessarily take an animal down
like lions will just use brute strength
hyenas use cunning and you can even go
on the internet and find uh
memes of this where hyenas will grab the
big animal by the balls
and just like we'll sneak up behind it
and bite its balls and you'll watch an
animal ten size ten times the size of
the hyena just slowly
go down it's brutal but it's [ __ ]
hilarious
you